bonsoir merci des trains directs sur rt
france on viens de l'entendre c'est un
test cliniques concluants selon vous est
ce qu'il peut suffire à relancer les
événements culturels de cette équipe
oui bonsoir et bien dark donne la foi
voyante diminuaient montrent qu'il est
possible d'innover et par cette
expérimentation ouvre la porte au retour
des activités cultural de masse puisque
quand même c'est un test qui portait sur
5000 participants avec effectivement un
succès total garanti tout de même là est
la sûreté sanitaire d'un espace comme
cela des des salles de concerts qui
peuvent accueillir 5000 personnes alors
c'est vrai qu'un protocole très strict a
été mise en place et après tout c'était
un protocole expérimental donc tout
avait été défini de façon très
rationnelle et qu'est ce qu'on peut
je dirais conclure de cette
expérimentation la première chose c'est
qu'effectivement la notion de densité
dans l'espace est importante c'est à
dire que dans cette dans l'organisation
de cet événement on s'était attaché à
respecter une certaine densité par mètre
carré dans la salle de spectacle la
deuxième chose c'est évidemment lite est
bon dont on voit qu'ils sont
incontournables dans ce type de
stratégie et le troisième élément et
c'est pas lui c'est pas finalement le
moindre des éléments c'est effectivement
l'adhésion des spectateurs et la
discipline des spectateurs dans le
processus d'organisation
ça pose quand même une question sur la
fiabilité des tests
rien n'est certain à ce niveau alors si
vous voulez c'est vrai que oui et non
parce que pour que effectivement un
patient et un taux de contagiosité
important et bien effectivement il faut
plutôt qu'il soit symptomatique et les
tests antigénique
bah finalement dans cette
expérimentation grandeur nature ont
montré tout leur intérêt puisque
effectivement même si on a un taux final
de 6 contaminés sur 5000 participants
donc je le rappelle 4 contaminée qui se
sont contaminées en dehors du concert ça
donne quand même une indication très
rassurante est très forte en faveur de
l'efficacité de ces tests sur ce type
d'événement
il ya un concertaient skate qui est en
train d'être organisées en france sous
l'égide du ministère de la santé
pourrait se tenir le 29 mai prochain
est-ce qu'il faut multiplier ses
expériences et jusqu'à quand pour
pouvoir les banaliser au final
écoutez ce qui est certain c'est qu'on
ne peut pas vivre sans la culture on
peut pas aujourd'hui ça fait un an et
demi que les pays européens ont baissé
leurs rideaux des principaux acteurs de
la culture
or la culture c'est le coeur de notre
vie est aujourd'hui effectivement tous
les moyens qui seront mis en oeuvre pour
remettre de la culture dans l'espace des
français des espagnols des européens en
général est une priorité nationale
alors d'un point de vue scientifique
vous pouvez répondre à cette question
ce genre d'expérience ça nous apprend
quoi sur le virus
concrètement sa transmission ça nous
apprend quand même beaucoup de choses en
tout cas ça confirme la stratégie mise
en oeuvre en espagne qui est une
stratégie de pilotage fin de l'épidémie
avec je vous le rappelle effectivement
des restaurants maintenant qu'ils sont
ouverts depuis relativement longtemps
des espaces publics qui sont préservés
ça nous rappelle l'importance 1
la densité de population dans un lieu ça
nous rappelle également deuxièmement
l'efficacité des mesures barrières et ça
nous rappelle également l'importance de
la discipline de l'adhésion de la
population
merci beaucoup à vous philippe
emmanuelli je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin libéral français à barcelone